PROFESSOR: I have
our final exam
schedule from the registrar.
It comes Tuesday morning
of exam week.
It's on the web page.
You won't miss it.
I want to remind you that the
midterm exam is on Wednesday,
March 16, that it starts at 9
not at 9:30 so that you're
less time-limited than you
would be otherwise.
It's a two-hour exam.
And it will cover basically up
through chapter eight, which
is Reed-Solomon codes.
And you're responsible for
anything that's been
discussed in class.
If we haven't discussed
it in class, then
don't worry about it.
All right.
Any questions about any
of those things?
It's 9 o'clock to 11 o'clock.
What's the underlined?
This line up here?
This says, "This class
goes from 9:30
to 11.00." Not 11:15.
That's for me, not for you,
although I've tried to lay off
some of the responsibility
on you.
OK, let's continue.
I hope to finish up chapter
six today, might not
completely finish it.
There are really three
topics left to go.
One is the orthogonality
and inner product
topic, which I skipped.
The second is Reed-Muller
codes, which is our main
objective in this chapter,
a family of useful codes.
And the last topic is why
making hard decisions
is not a good idea.
And so I'll try to say
as much as I can
about those three things.
Just to remind you of where
we are, we're in the
power-limited regime.
We're trying to design good,
small-signal constellations,
or moderate-sized signal
constellations now, with
nominal spectral efficiency,
less than two bits per two
dimensions.
The technique we're using is
we're going to start from a
binary linear block code
in Hamming space.
And we're going to take the
Euclidean image of that and
hope it's a good constellation
in Euclidean space.
And as we were just talking
about before class, the fact
that a linear code is a subspace
of F2 to the n means
it's true if and only if,
really, it has the group
property, which in Euclidean
space leads to a geometrical
uniformity property.
We haven't proved that
in its full scope.
But we have noticed that from
every code word, every code
word has the same distance
profile to
all other code words.
And in particular, the minimum
distance is the minimum weight
of any non-zero code word.
That's the main juice we've
squeezed out of
that at this point.
So we've now been talking a
little bit about the algebra
of binary linear block codes.
We've characterized them
basically by three parameters,
n, k, d, where n is the length
of the code, k is the
dimension of the code, d is the
minimum Hamming distance
of the code.
In the literature, this is what
you'll mainly find, in
the n, k, d code.
We have a subsidiary parameter,
the number of words
of minimum distance d, which
we're going to need to get the
error coefficient, or a
union-bound expression.
This has less prominence
in the literature.
Given just these numbers, we get
a couple of key parameters
of our constellation.
One is its nominal spectral
efficiency, which is 2k over n
bits per two dimension,
upper bounded by 2.
Of course, often in the coding
literature, you talk about in
a more natural quantity,
which is k over n,
called the code rate.
Maybe I shouldn't call it cap-R,
because R is used for
the code rate in bits
per second.
This means bit per symbol.
So just let me call this rate.
But when you're reading the
coding literature, the rate of
the code means how many
information bits per how many
transmitted bits.
And for n, k, d binary linear
block code, it's k over m.
And the nominal spectral
efficiency is just twice that,
since we measure it per
two dimensions.
OK, and even more importantly,
we get the union bound
estimate in terms of a couple
of simple parameters.
It's just an error coefficient,
Kb, the number of
nearest neighbors per bit
times this Q function
expression, which always has 2Eb
over N_0 in it, multiplied
by this multiplicative factor,
which we call the coding gain,
which is just kd over n.
And this is equal to one
for a 1,1,1 code.
Now you know coding.
So anything else?
Our basic effort is to get
a larger coding gain by
constructing more complicated
codes.
This parameter here, which we
need in order to actually plot
the curve and estimate the
effective coding gain -- the
effective coding gain is derated
from the nominal
coding gain by a rule of thumb,
which depends on Kb.
It's every factor of 2 in Kb
costs you 0.2 dB, roughly in
the right range, if it's not too
big, all those qualifiers.
But it's a good engineering
rule of thumb.
And that's just the number of
nearest neighbors per code
word divided by k.
And so our object here is to
see how well we can do.
And the Reed-Muller codes will
be an infinite family of codes
that give us a pretty good idea
of what can be achieved
for a variety of n, k, d that
kind of cover the waterfront.
That's why I talk about
them first.
They're all so very simple.
OK, but first, we forgot to talk
about orthogonality and
inner products and duality, both
from a geometric point of
view and from an algebraic
point of view.
And so I want to go back
and recover that.
The definition of an inner
product between x and y, where
x and y are both binary
n-tuples, is, as you'd expect,
a sort of dot product
expression, a component-wise
product, the sum over k of xk
yk, where all the arithmetic
here is in the binary
field, F2.
And well, this clearly has the
bilinearity properties that
you expect of an inner product
that's linear in x for a fixed
y or vice versa.
But it doesn't turn out to have
the geometric properties
that you expect.
We can define orthogonality,
this is another definition, in
the usual way.
x and y are said to
be orthogonal --
do that better.
x is said to be orthogonal to
y if and only if their inner
product is 0, which is the same
definition you know from
real and complex
vector spaces.
OK.
But the overall moral I want you
to get from this is while
this inner product behaves
absolutely as you expect in an
algebraic sense, it behaves very
different from what you
expect in a geometric sense.
So the algebra's fine.
The geometry is screwy.
All right.
That's the catch word
to keep in mind.
Why is that?
Where does this inner
product live?
It's F2 valued, right?
I'm just doing this sum in
binary space, and the result
is either 0 or 1.
So when are two n-tuples
orthogonal?
Simply if they have an even
number of places in which
they're both equal to 1.
Is there a question?
In particular, suppose I try to
define a norm in the usual
way, like that.
Is that going to have
the properties that
I'd want of a norm?
No.
Why?
Because one of the basic
properties we want of a norm
is strict positivity, that the
norm of x is equal to 0 if and
only if x is equal to 0.
That's clearly not true here.
What's the requirement for the
inner product of x with itself
to be equal to 0, in
other words x to be
orthogonal with itself?
It just simply has to have
an even number of 1's.
If it has an even number
of 1's, then this
so-called norm is 0.
If there's an odd
number, it's 1.
So it's perfectly possible for
a vector to be orthogonal to
itself, a non-zero vector to
be orthogonal to itself.
And that's basically where all
the trouble comes from in a
geometric sense.
AUDIENCE: So which of them would
be [INAUDIBLE] here?
PROFESSOR: It's mod-2.
It's in F2.
All the arithmetic rules
are from F2 which is
mod-2 rules, correct.
So, good.
This means at the most
fundamental level, we don't
have a Hilbert space here.
We don't have a projection
theorem.
Projection theorem is the basic
tool we use in Euclidean
spaces, more generally,
Hilbert spaces.
Just say that every vector
can be partitioned.
In a given space and its
orthogonal space, we can
express a vector as the sum of
its projection onto the space
and the projection onto the
orthogonal space, which are
two orthogonal vectors.
So it's an orthogonal
decomposition.
So we have nothing like the
projection theorem here.
Therefore we have nothing like,
we don't necessarily
have orthonormal or even
orthogonal basis for subspaces.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You do have a unique
orthogonal complement.
I'll get to that in a second.
But for instance, we might have
that a subspace can be
orthogonal to itself.
That's what the problem is.
For instance, 0, 0, and 1,
1 is a nice, little,
one-dimensional subspace.
And what's it's orthogonal
subspace?
It's itself.
We may not have an orthogonal
basis for a subspace.
And for an example of that, I'll
give you our favorite 3,
2, 2 code, as I'll
now call it.
It consists of these
four code words.
A set of generators for this
code consists of any two of
the non-zero code words.
You can generate all of the code
words as binary linear
combinations of any
two of these.
But no two of these
are orthogonal.
So there's clearly
no orthogonal
basis for that code.
We shouldn't expect to find
orthogonal basis, orthogonal
decomposition, so all of these
sorts of tools that we relied
on heavily in 6.450 in
Euclidean spaces.
OK, so this is just a great
caution to the student.
Don't expect Hamming space to
have the same geometric
properties as Euclidean space.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Nothing special.
It's just finite fields have
a different geometry.
In F2, there's really only one
geometry you would impose,
which is the Hamming geometry.
In other finite fields, there
actually could be more than
one geometry.
But let's say the algebraic
properties, however, you can
still count on.
For instance, n, k, d
code C has, as we've
already shown, a basis.
It has k dimensions.
It has a basis g1 up to gk of
k, linearly independent,
though not necessarily
orthogonal basis vectors.
So we can always write the code
as the set of all u g
such that u is a k-tuple of
information bits, let's say.
In other words, this is a
compressed form for the set of
all binary linear combinations
of these generators, where
I've written what's called a
generator matrix, g as a k by
n matrix, whose rows are
these generators.
And I've multiplied on the left
with a row vector u, if
I'm doing it in matrix terms.
You can do this more abstractly
just as a linear
transformation.
And side comment, notice that
in coding theory, it's
conventional to write vectors
as row vectors, whereas in
every other subject you take,
it's conventional to write
vectors as column vectors.
Why is this?
Is there some deep,
philosophical reason?
No.
It's just the way people started
to do it in coding
theory back at the beginning,
and then everybody has
followed them.
I may have even had something
to do with this myself.
And I'll tell you the reason I
like to write vectors as row
vectors is I don't have
to write a little
t up next to them.
That's the deep philosophical
reason.
It's like driving on the right
side or the left side.
Obviously, you could have chosen
how to do it one way or
another back in the beginning.
But once you've chosen it,
you better stick with it.
There's actually some insight
involved here.
This is sort of associated with
a block diagram, where we
take k bits, and we run
it through this linear
transformation.
And as a result, we get out,
what shall I write, x n bits.
And in block diagrams, we tend
to take the input bits from
the left and proceed to
the right, left to
right kind of thing.
So this formula reflects this
left to right picture, whereas
I'd say the deeper reason why
you usually see G u in system
theory is that G is regarded
as an operator
that operates on u.
It's kind of a G of u.
And so that's why it's more
natural to think of this as
being a column vector,
because then, we
have a different picture.
G is the operator that
somehow transforms u.
But these are all side
comments, obviously.
They don't really matter
for anything.
All right, just remember that
vectors are row vectors.
OK.
Let's define the dual code in
the natural way, as the
orthogonal code.
Say C dual.
The definition is that C dual is
the set of all n-tuples y,
such that x, the inner product
between x and y is 0.
In other words, y is orthogonal
to x for all the x
and C. It's the set of all
n-tuples that are orthogonal
to all the words in C under
our F2 definition of inner
product orthogonality.
OK, so that's a natural
definition.
For example, as I've already
shown you, if C is 0, 0, 1, 1,
then C dual is 0, 0, 1, 1.
If C were 0, 0, 0, 1, then C
dual would be 0, 0, what?
1, 0.
Thank you.
Because 1, 1 is not orthogonal
to this, 0, 1 and is not
orthogonal to this.
So we simply go through
and pick it out.
Now as I said, the algebraic
properties of the
dual code are OK.
I emphasize they're algebraic.
If C is an n, k code, in other
words, has dimension k, what
do you expect the parameters
of C dual to be?
Its length is what?
It's n, of course.
And what's its dimension
going to be?
If C has dimension k, what do
you guess the dimension of C
dual is going to be?
Just guess from Euclidean
spaces, or any --
it's n minus k.
The dual space has dimension
n minus k.
And that holds.
In the notes, I give two
proofs for this.
There's the conventional coding
theory textbook proof,
which involves writing down
a generator matrix for C k
generators, reducing it to a
canonical form, called the
systematic form, where there's
some k by k identity matrix
and a n minus k by k
parity check part.
Then, by inspection, you can
write down a generator matrix
for C dual.
And you find it has dimension
n minus k.
It's kind of a klutzy proof,
in my opinion.
A second, more elegant proof,
but one that you don't have
the background for yet, is to
use simply the fundamental
theorem of homomorphisms.
This is in some sense
an image.
This is the dual of an image,
which is a kernel.
You work out the dimensions
from that.
I am still in search of an
elegant, elementary proof.
And anyone who can come up
with a proof suitable for
chapter six gets a gold star.
Believe me, the gold star will
be very valuable to you.
OK, so exercise for any student
so inclined, give me a
nice proof of this.
It's surprisingly hard.
And I can't say I've spent great
quantities of my life on
it, but I've spent
some time on it.
So anyway, the dimensions come
out as I hope you would
expect, based on your
past experience.
And I won't give you
a proof in class.
You get the fundamental duality
relationship, that the
dual of C dual, what would
you expects that to be?
C. OK.
In words, C is the set of all
n-uples that are orthogonal to
all the n-tuples in C dual.
OK.
So this actually means that I
can specify C. If I know C
dual, I know C. Give me C dual,
the set of all code
words orthogonal to it
tells me what C is.
So this implies that I can write
C in the following form.
C is the set of all, just
emulating this, y n F2 to the
n such that x, y equals zero
for all x in C dual.
I probably should have
interchanged x and y for this.
x such that x, y equals
0 for all --
this is symmetrical.
The inner product of x and y is
equal to the inner product
of y and x.
So I don't care how
I write it.
OK, so I can actually
specify a code by a
set of parity checks.
Now suppose I have a generator
matrix, call it H, namely a
set of generators, H1 through
Hn minus k, for C dual.
I'm going to have a set of
n minus k generators.
Then I hope it's obvious that
I can test whether x is
orthogonal to all of C dual by
just checking whether it's
orthogonal to all of
these generators.
So I would now have C is the set
of all x n-tuples x such
that x, H, j equals
zero, all j.
OK.
I've just got to test
orthogonality to each of these
generators.
In other words, in each
of these is what we
call a parity check.
We take the inner product of x
with a certain n-tuple, and we
ask whether parity checks.
In other words, we ask whether
the subset of positions in
which H, j is equal to 1, in
those positions, whether x has
an even number of 1's.
Get very concrete about it.
So writing this out in matrix
form, the test is C is the set
of x in F2 to the n such that
x h-transpose equals 0.
That's just a matrix form of
what I've written up there.
So let me picture
it like this.
Here the test is, I take
x, which is n bits.
I put it into what's
called a parity
checker or syndrome reformer.
And I ask whether this is 0.
We call this, in general,
the syndrome.
And we ask whether it's 0.
If we get a 0, we say
x is in the code.
If it's not 0, then x
is not in the code.
That's the test.
So when we summarize, we really
have two dual ways of
characterizing a code, which
you will see in the
literature.
We have a generator matrix, we
might give a k by n generator
matrix for the code.
And then the code is specified
as C is the set of all U g
such that U n F2 to the k.
In other words, this is an
image representation.
We take C as the image of
a linear transformation.
We call G a linear
transformation.
It goes from Fk to F2 to
the k to F2 to the n.
And then the code is simply
the image of this
transformation algebraically.
OK.
Or we can specify it by means
of a parity check matrix, H,
which is the generator matrix
of the dual code.
So this would be the parity
check matrix for the dual code
G. h is the generator matrix
of the dual code.
And we ask whether --
now we specify it as I have up
here, simply the x and F2 to
the n such that x
H_t equals 0.
And this is what's called a
kernel representation, because
it's the kernel of a linear
transformation defined by H2
from F2 to the end, down
to, this is a m
by n minus k matrix.
So the syndrome is actually
an n-minus-k-tuple.
The elements of the syndrome are
the n minus k individual
bits, parity check bits.
OK.
And sometimes it's more
convenient to characterize the
code in one way, and sometimes
it's more convenient to
characterize it in
the other way.
For instance, we were talking
last time about the n, n minus
1, 2 single parity check code,
or the even weight code, the
set of all even weight
n-tuples, which has
dimension n minus 1.
And in general, for high-rate
codes especially, it may be
simpler to give the parity
check representation.
What is the dual code?
Let's call this C.
C dual is what?
C dual is what we call the
n, 1, n repetition code.
In other words, it has
dimension one.
It has two code words, the all-0
word and the all-1 word.
Clearly, the all-1 word is
orthogonal to all of the even
weight words.
And vice versa, a word is even
weight if and only if it's
orthogonal to all 1's.
So in this case, what is
the generator matrix?
We had a generator matrix last
time consisting of n minus 1
weight 2 code words all arranged
in a kind of double
diagonal pattern.
That's OK.
But that's an n minus
1 by n matrix.
Most people would say it's
easier to say, OK, what's the
parity check matrix?
The parity check matrix in this
case, H, is simply a one
by n matrix consisting
of all one's.
And what's the characterization
of the code?
The code consists of all
the words that are
orthogonal to this.
And that is why we call it
single parity check code.
There's one parity check.
And if you pass the parity
check, you're in the code.
And if you don't, you're not.
OK, so we see that these,
first of all, here's an
example of dual codes.
Are their dimensions correct?
They are.
Is each on characterized
correctly as
the dual of the other?
It is.
So we've passed that.
This is intended to make point
C. So it's a good example.
One final thing is suppose I
have a code with generator
matrix G and another code with
generator matrix H. Are they
each other's dual
codes are not?
And the answer is pretty obvious
from all of this.
Yes, they are.
Let me a substitute in here,
x is supposed to
be equal to U g.
So another requirement is that
UGH_t equals zero for all u.
And without belaboring the
point, the 5, 2 codes with
generator matrix G and H, they
are dual codes if and only if
they have the right dimension,
one is n, k, and the other is
n, n minus k, and we satisfy
G H_t equals zero.
Basically, this is the matrix
of inner products of the
generators of C with the
generators of C dual.
And if we have k generators
that are all orthogonal to
these n minus k generators,
then they must be the
generators of dual codes.
That's is kind of intuitive
and natural.
All right, so again, this is a
concise form that you would
actually, probably most
commonly find in the
literature.
It's not hard to get to.
OK, so in this course, we're
probably going to talk quite a
bit about orthogonality.
Duality is very powerful, but
we're not going to be using it
very much in this course,
I believe.
I'll mention duality
whenever there's a
duality property to mention.
But in general, I'm not going
to spend an awful
lot of time on it.
But it's important you know
about it, particularly if you
were going to go on and do
anything in this subject.
And at an elementary level, it's
nice to know that we have
two possible representations,
and one is often going to be
simpler than the other.
Use the simple one.
In general, use the
representation for the
low-rate code to determine
the high-rate code.
OK.
Any questions on this?
I've now finished up
the preparatory.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
that every basis for
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's necessary
and sufficient, right.
OK, Reed-Muller codes.
Why do I talk about
Reed-Muller codes?
First of all, they give us an
infinite family of codes, so
we can see what happens as n
gets large, as k goes from 0
to n, whose parameters are
sort of representative.
They aren't necessarily the best
codes that we know of.
They're very simple, as I will
show, to construct and to
characterize their parameters,
so we can do all the proofs in
half an hour here.
And they're not so bad.
In terms of the parameters n,
k, d, the Reed-Muller codes,
up to length 32, are the best
ones we know of, at least for
their parameters.
There is no 32, 16 code that's
better than a 32, 16, eight
Reed-Muller code.
There's no 32k, eight code that
has k greater than 16,
all those sorts of things.
Actually, I'm not 100%
sure of that.
So for short block lengths,
they're as good as BCH codes,
or any of the codes that were
discovered subsequently.
For even longer lengths, up to
64, 128, 256, they are going
to be slightly sub-optimal in
terms of n, k, d, as we'll see
in some cases.
But they still are very good
codes to look at in terms of
performance versus complexity.
The decoding algorithm that
I'm going to talk about
eventually for them is a
trellis-based decoding
algorithm, and a maximum
likelihood
decoding algorithm within.
They can be maximum likelihood
decoded very simply by these
trellis-based algorithms.
And that's not true of more
elaborate classes of codes.
So from a performance versus
complexity point of view,
they're still good codes to look
at for block lengths up
to 100, 200.
As we get up to higher block
lengths, then we'll be talking
about much more random-like,
non-algebraic codes in the
final section of the course.
This is the way you actually
get to pass it.
You don't worry about n, k, d.
Right now, we're talking about
moderate complexity, moderate
performance.
OK, so they were invented in
1954 independently by Irving
Reed and, I think it was, David
Muller, D. Muller, in
two separate papers,
which shows they
weren't too hard to find.
As you'll see, they're very
easy to construct.
They're basically based on a
length-doubling construction.
So we start off with codes
of length or length 2.
And then from that, we build up
codes of length 4, 8, 16,
32, and so forth.
So in general, their lengths are
equal to a power of 2, and
m is the parameter that denotes
the power of 2.
So we only get certain block
lengths, which are equal to
powers of 2.
They have a second parameter, r,
whose significance is that
d is 2 to the m minus r for 0,
less than or equal to r, less
than or equal to m.
Or some people, including me,
are going to put the lower
limit at minus 1, just to be
able to include one more code
in this family at each length.
But this is just a
matter of taste.
You'll see this is a very
special case, the minus 1.
So let's guess what some of
these codes are going to be.
So we have two parameters, m,
which can be any integer 0 or
higher, so the lengths will be
1,2,4, so forth, and r, which
goes basically from 0 to m,
which means the distances will
go from 2 to the m down to 1.
And what are some of the
basic codes that we're
always going to find?
We always write Rm
of little rm.
I'm not sure I completely
approve of how the notation
goes for these codes, but
that's the way it is.
So it's this notation.
That means the Reed-Muller code
with the parameters m and
r is written Rm of r, m.
All right.
So Rm of m, m, this is going
to be a code of length 2 to
the m and distance 1.
What do you suppose that's
going to be?
This is always going to
be the 2 to the m 1.
Sorry, the distance is 1.
So it's going to be the 2 to
the m, 1 universe code, in
other words, simply the set of
all 2 to the m-tuples, which
has Hamming distance 1.
OK.
RM of 0, m, what's
that going to be?
This is a code now that has
length 2 to the m and minimum
distance 2 to the m.
We know what that has to be.
It has to be the 2 to the m, 1,
2 to the m repetition code,
a very low-rate code,
dimension one.
OK.
And then if we like, we can
go one step further.
There is a code below
this code.
This is the highest-rate
code you can get.
This, however, is not the
lowest-rate code you can get.
What's the lowest rate code
of length 2 to the m?
Well, it's one that has
dimension zero and minimum
distance infinity.
And I don't think I ever defined
this convention.
But for the trivial code that
consists of simply the all-0
word, what's it's minimum
distance?
Undefined, or infinity,
if you like.
So this is the trivial code.
So if we want, we can include
the trivial code in this
family just by defining
it like this.
And it works for some things.
It doesn't work for
all things.
d, for instance.
This definition holds only
for r between 0 and m.
It doesn't hold for r equals
minus 1, because there the
distance is infinite.
OK, so let's start out and
get even more explicit.
We want to start with
m equals 0.
In that case, we have only Rm of
0, 0, and Rm of minus 1, 0.
And this is going to be the
one by either of these.
The universe code is equal
to the repetition code.
It's the 1, 1, 1 code.
And this is the 1,
0, infinity code.
And that's really the only two
codes that you can think of
that have length 1, right?
This is the one that consists
of 0 and 1, and this is the
one that consists of 0.
I don't think there are any
other binary linear block
codes of length 1.
So that's a start, not
very interesting.
Let's go up to length 2.
So m is going to
be equal to 1.
Here, Rm of 1, 1 is going
to be length 2.
And it's going to be the
universe code, so it's only
going to have distance 1.
Rm of 0, 1 is going to be length
2, but it's going to be
the repetition code.
And Rm of minus 1, 1 is going
to be 2, 0, infinity.
OK, so there are really the
only three sensible
codes of length 2.
This is the only one
of dimension two.
of dimension zero.
There are other ones of
dimension one, but they don't
have minimum distance 2, so
they're not very good for
coding purposes.
So this kind of lists all the
good coding codes of length 2.
All right.
So now let me introduce the
length-doubling construction.
Let me make the point, first of
all, that all these codes
are nested.
What does that mean?
That means that his code is a
sub-code of this code, which
is a sub-code of this code.
And that's going to be, in
general, a property of
Reed-Muller codes.
We're going to get a family.
And each lower one is going
to be a sub-code of the
next-higher one, which is going
to be easy to prove
recursively.
All right.
This is the key thing to know
about Reed-Muller codes, how
do you construct them.
Once you understand the
construction, then you can
derive all the properties.
It's called the u, u plus v
construction for obvious reasons.
Apparently, Plotkin was the
first person to show this.
I think Reed and Muller had two
different constructions,
and neither one of them was the
u, u plus v construction.
Reed, in particular, talked
about Boolean functions.
All right.
But this is the way I recommend
you to think about
constructing them.
And it's simply defined
as follows.
We assume we've already
constructed the Reed-Muller
codes of length m minus 1.
It's a recursive parameter,
m minus 1.
Now we're going to construct all
the Reed-Muller codes of
parameter m of length
2 to the m.
How are we going to do it?
We want to construct
Rm of r, m.
And we'll say it's the set of
all code words which consist
of two halves, a pair of
n-tuples of half the length.
so the two halves are going to
be u and u plus v, where I
choose u and u plus
v as follows.
u is in Rm of r minus 1, m.
And so what does that mean?
Sorry, it's got to
be m minus 1.
So it's got to be
half the length.
Is that right? r m minus
1, v is in Rm of r
minus 1, m minus 1.
Somebody who has the notes,
like my valuable teaching
assistant, might check whether
I got it right or not.
Let's see.
What are going to be the
parameters of these codes?
They both have n equals
2 to the m minus 1.
The distance here is 2 to the m
minus 1 minus r minus 1, so
the distance here is 2 to the
m minus r, which is the
distance that we want to
achieve for this code.
And the distance here is 2 to
the m minus r minus 1, which
is half the distance we want
to achieve for this code.
So we reach down, if we wanted
to construct now a code of
length four and distance two,
we would construct it from
these two codes, the one of half
the length with distance
2, and the one of half the
length with half the distance,
distance 1.
So we would somehow use this to
get a code of length 4 and
distance 2.
And we don't know
yet what k is.
OK.
So we're going to use these
two codes to construct a
larger code.
Is the construction clear?
All right.
So let's now derive some
properties from this
construction, and from the fact
that we've started from a
set of codes.
Let's say we start from
length two codes.
Or we could start
from length one.
You could satisfy yourself that
this construction applied
to the length one codes gives
the length two codes.
I won't go through
that exercise.
So we have some set of
codes, m minus 1.
What's the first thing
we notice?
Obviously, the length is what
we want, because we've put
together two 2-to-the-m minus
1-tuples, and 2 times 2 to the
m minus 1 is 2 to the m.
So we've constructed a set
of 2-to-the-m-tuples.
The length of the resulting
code is 2 to the m.
This is Rm r, m, constructed
in this way.
Second, it's linear.
It's a linear code.
All we have to check is
the group property.
If we add two code words of this
form, we're going to get
another code word of that form,
from the fact that these
guys are linear, yes.
OK.
So it is a linear code,
that's important.
Then we might ask, what's
its dimension?
How many code words are there?
Well, do I get a unique code
word for every combination of
u and v. And however you want
to convince yourself, you
obviously do.
If I'm given this word here, I
can deduce from it what was u,
that's simply the first
half of it.
Subtract u from the second
half of it, and I
find out what v is.
So there's a one-to-one map
between all possible pairs, u,
v, and all possible
new code words.
And so what that means is, let
me call it the dimension of
the code with parameters r,
m is simply the sum of the
dimensions of the codes with
parameters r, m minus 1 and r
minus 1, m minus 1.
So for instance, in this
hypothesized code here, if I
want to know the dimension,
well, I take all possible
combinations of words
here and words here.
How many are there?
There are eight.
It has dimension three.
So I'm going to get a 4, 3, 2,
code, which it's not too hard
to see is the single parity
check code of length 4.
All right.
So that's how I do it.
I simply add up the dimensions
of the two contributing codes.
Not a very nice formula.
In the homework, you do a
combinatoric exercise that
gives you a somewhat more closed
form of the formula.
But I think this is actually
the most useful one.
In any case, we eventually get
a table that shows what all
these things are anyway.
Now, just as a fine point, I
want to assert that if I start
out from a set of nested codes,
then I come up with a
set of nested codes, at the
next highest level.
That, again, is sort
of obvious.
If these guys were nested, then
I get the appropriate --
if I take u, u plus v
from sub-codes, I'm
going to get a sub-code.
Look at the notes if you want
more than that little bit of
hand-waving.
OK, that's something I need
for the next thing.
I want to find out what d is.
What's the minimum
distance here?
Of course, my objective is
to make it equal to 2
to the m minus r.
Did I succeed?
What are the possibilities
for u, u plus v?
The possibilities are that
they're both 0, or that this
one is 0 and this is not equal
to 0, or this is not equal to
0 and this is 0, or that they're
both not equal to 0.
And I'm going to consider
those four cases.
Since every linear code include
the all-0 word, it's
certainly possible that this
comes out at 0, 0.
The only possibility for this
to come out 0, 0 is if I
choose u equals 0.
Then I have to choose
v equals 0.
So there's one-code word of
weight 0 in my new code.
But that's OK.
If there were two code words
with weight 0, well, then the
dimension would be wrong.
This is in effect a proof that
the kernel is just 0, 0.
And so the dimension is OK.
It's a one-to-one map.
All right.
So I don't really have
to worry about that.
I'm going to get one all-0
word in my new code.
I can afford one all-0 word.
I'm always going to have
to have it anyway.
It's linear.
All right, so these are the
more interesting cases.
Suppose the first half is 0, but
the second half is not 0.
That implies that u is 0.
That implies that the second
half is just v,
which is not 0.
So v must be a non-zero code
word in this code, which has
minimum distance 2
to the n minus r.
So in this case, I prove that
the distance is greater than
or equal to 2 to
the m minus r.
Similarly, suppose this one
is not 0, but this is 0.
OK, if that's 0, it can only be
because I chose u equal to
some v. and that means the first
half, then, is that v.
So again, v is in this
code that has
enough minimum distance.
So in this case, I proved that
the code word has weight 2 to
the m minus r.
And finally, let's take
the case where
they're both non-zero.
In that case, u could be an
arbitrary word in this code
which only has distance
2 to the m r minus 1.
So the first half is going to
have weight at least 2 to the
m minus r minus 1, but
that's all I can say
about the first half.
But now the second half,
what is this?
This is a higher-rate
code than this.
This, by the nesting property,
is a sub-code of this.
So if I add a word in a sub-code
to a word in the
code, I'm going to get another
word in this code.
So u plus v is still in this
Reed-Muller code, still has a
minimum weight, if it's
non-zero, of 2 to the m
minus r minus 1.
So the distance is at least this
in the first half, this
in the second half.
And that's, of course,
still good enough.
OK.
So by this construction.
I've assured that I'm going to
get a d greater than or equal
to 2 to the m minus r.
And of course, you can easily
find cases of equality, where
it's only 2 to the m minus r.
If this has a word of weight 2
to the m minus r, then you can
clearly set up one like
this that has weight 2
to the m minus r.
Just pick one of the
minimum-weight code words as
v, and u as 0.
So the minimum distance
is 2 to the m minus r.
All righty.
So those are all the
properties we need.
And then, I like to display
these properties in a tableau
which you have in the notes,
which goes as follows.
Let's just start listing
these codes.
Here are the length 1 ones.
We only found 2 of them, 1,
1, 1, and 1, 0, infinity.
So there are two codes
of length 1.
Now it turns out that if you
combine these according to the
u, u plus v construction, you
get 2, 1, 2, where the weight
2, 1 is just the --
you take the first half is 1,
and the second half is 1.
So you can build this
in the same way.
And similarly, we can say just
by definition, we're always
going to put a universe code at
the top and a trivial code
at the bottom.
So now I've listed all
my Reed-Muller
codes with length 2.
Now to construct the
ones of length 4.
Again, I'll put a universe code
at the top, a trivial
code at the bottom.
I'll use my construction now to
create a 4, 3, 2 code here.
I'm just using all
these properties.
And down here, my construction,
when you combine
these two things, you always
get a repetition code,
again, 4, 1, 4.
And I guess I've hand-waved.
Exercise for the student,
prove that combining a
repetition code with a trivial
code under the u, u plus v
construction always gives a
double length repetition code.
It's clear.
v is always the all-0 word.
u is either all-0 or all-1.
So we get two words, one of
which is all-0, and one of
which is all-1, double length.
All right.
So now I can just go on
indefinitely, and without a
great deal of effort.
Here I find that k is 7, just by
adding up these two things.
The 8, this gives me an 8, 4.
4 code.
This gives me an 8.
1, 8 code, and similarly
down here.
And this, I now just
turn the crank.
16, 16, 1.
I always put that on top.
The next one is 16, 15, 2.
Next one is 16, 11, 4.
After a while, you don't know
what you're going to get.
But you get something.
You've proved that all of
these codes exist, that
they're all linear.
They all have the n, k, d that
we've specified, and that
furthermore, they're nested.
And a final property, which you
might suspect, looking at
these tables, is that the dual
of a Reed-Muller code is also
a Reed-Muller code.
And they're paired up according
to k and n minus k.
Let's see.
15 and 11 is 26.
11 and five is 16.
5 and 1 is 6.
And 32, 1, 32, and so forth.
Did you see how I proved that
all these codes exist?
And if I continued, I could get
arbitrarily long codes,
one of your simple homework
problems is just to do this,
continue this for 64
and 128, see what
additional codes you get.
And so I now have this infinite
family it of that
kind of covers the space n, k,
d in some sort of sparse way.
But it indicates how
k and d go with n.
And we come back to our original
question, how well
can we do with binary
linear block codes.
Well, here's some binary linear
block codes, pretty
close to the best we
can find, actually.
The ones I've listed
up here are all as
good as we can find.
And how well can we do?
Really, we don't need to know
much to evaluate the
performance of, say, 32, 6, 8
code, which is now getting to
be a pretty substantial code,
with 2 to the 16 code words,
to 65,536 code words.
So we built a fairly sizable
constellation here in a
32-dimensional Euclidean
space.
And how good is it?
Let's take 32, 16, 8.
Can I graph its probability
of error per bit, a
good estimate of it?
Can I?
Is there any information
I'm lacking?
OK, I've been talking too long,
because when I go to the
class, I'd like a
little response.
So you were going to
say something?
AUDIENCE: We don't
have [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, let me tell you
that the n, d is approximately
600-something, so
let's say 630.
It's probably not
exactly correct.
In the notes I give a
formula for n, d --
a formula that I don't
derive, that is known
for Reed-Muller codes.
And from that, you can compute
n, d for any of these codes.
This parameter is m, r.
All right.
So I'll give you n, d as well.
Now can I get the good estimate
for the probability
of error per bit?
How do I do that?
Union-bound estimate.
All right, so what's it
going to look like?
What are the two subsidiary
parameters I need?
One is the coding gain, right?
What is the nominal coding gain
of this 32, 16, 8 code?
Come on, this is not a difficult
computation.
OK, what's k over n?
1/2?
I think we can all
do that one.
What's the nominal
coding gain?
Take 1/2 times d, 8.
So now our coding gain is
4, which is what in dB?
6 dB.
Wow, gee whiz.
I've already got a nominal
coding gain of 6 dB.
Remember, my whole gap was,
depending on how I measured
it, 9 or 10 or 11 dB.
This looks like already a
sizable fraction of the gap,
with just a simple
construction.
Well, we better pay attention
to this error coefficient as
well, or the number of
nearest neighbors.
Kb is, let's just take a rough
estimate here, what's this
going to be?
About 40.
That's good.
It's just this divided by 16.
So there are about 40 nearest
neighbors per bit.
How much is that going
to cost us?
Not so good.
Well, it's a little bit more
than 5 factors of 2.
Maybe 5 and a 1/2 factors.
It's less than 5 and a 1/2.
So this very roughly,
something will
cost me about 1 dB.
And so I get an effective
coding gain of 5 dB.
That's my first very
gross estimate.
All right, well,
it's not 6 dB.
It's only 5 dB.
That's still not bad.
Again, if I really wanted to
know what this was, I would
write this out as 40 or whatever
it is times Q to the
square root of four times
2Eb over N_0.
And can I plot that quantity?
Yes, if I have MATLAB.
Or actually, all I need
is my baseline.
So if this is my baseline, which
went through 9.6 dB at
10 to the minus 5, then we
remember how to plot that.
I just take this whole curve
bodily, and I move
it 6 dB to the left.
So I get the same curve, this
is not very good, going
through 3.6 dB.
Sorry about that.
How's that?
Get it way down here.
But then I also have to raise
it by a factor of 40.
So it really looks
more like that.
That's really going to go more
through about 4.6 dB or
something like that.
That's what these calculations
are, Ashish took
you through, I believe.
And so while 6 dB was my
nominal coding gain, my
effective coding gain is 5 dB.
But still, hey, not bad.
I have very easily been able to
construct a code that gives
you about 5 dB of coding gain.
Is there any fly in
this ointment?
Can I just go out and
build it now?
I need a decoder.
Who said that?
Thank you.
Good point.
What's the decoding method
assumed for this code?
Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Just a table
right now.
PROFESSOR: Just a table,
based on what?
I get some kind of received
n-tuple, which is actually
just a random, some kind of
vector in 32-dimensional
space, 32 numbers,
real numbers.
And really, I'm assuming minimum
distance decoding.
So in principle, I want to
compute the distance to each
of the 2 to the 1/6th,
65,000 code words.
And actually, nowadays, you
might just do that.
That's not a formidable task.
Back when I got into this
business, that would have been
considered outrageous.
But nowadays, you could keep
up a pretty good decoding
rate, even doing 65,000 distance
computations and just
finding the best one.
That would do it.
That would give you
this performance.
But of course, we are going to
be looking for somewhat more
efficient decoding schemes
than that.
All right.
So at this point, that's the
only fly in the ointment.
We have a way of getting this
kind of error curve, provided
that we're willing to do
exhaustive maximum likelihood
or minimum distance decoding.
And furthermore, we
can continue.
It's also instructive to
see what happens as
we let n go to infinity.
What are we going to get
with this construction?
We pretty well know.
These are all going to be
universe codes, which are not
very interesting to us.
They all have a nominal
coding gain of one,
and are just useless.
They're basically just
send a bit 32 times,
send 32 bits, I mean.
OK, what are these
codes along here?
Let me start there.
These are all single
parity check codes.
What's the nominal
coding gain?
Well, as we get out here,
what does the
nominal coding gain approach?
The code rate approaches 1.
The code distance stays at 2.
So the nominal coding gain goes
to 2 or 3 or dB, at a
rate of 1 or a nominal spectral
efficiency of 2.
OK.
Well, these are totally
simple codes, single
parity check codes.
And even with that, it looks
like we can get 3
dB of coding gain.
But what's the number of
nearest neighbors here?
Number of nearest neighbors
is just n, n minus 1
over 2, n choose 2.
So the number of even dividing
by k, which is n minus 1, we
still get a Kb that goes
up linearly with n.
So what's in fact going
to happen to the
effective coding gain?
The nominal coding gain will
go up and reach an
asymptote of 3 dB.
This is nominal coding gain.
But somewhere out here, as this
has reached an asymptote,
the effective coding gain is
always going to be less, and
it's going to have
to bend over.
And according to our rule of
thumb, it'll eventually go
back through 0, because the
cost just keeps going up
linearly in terms of Kb.
So the effective coding
gain is not as great.
It has a peak for some n.
And so there's some maximum
effective coding gain, which
again I've left for you
as a homework problem,
that's less than 3 dB.
And I'll give you a hint that
it's of the order of 2 dB.
It's pretty easy to work out in
the five minutes before the
next class, not a difficult
problem to find out when this
thing reaches its maximum.
But still, these are
very simple codes.
We'll see in a second they
have an extremely simple
minimum distance decoding
algorithm
called Wagner decoding.
It's trivial, not hard to do
minimum distance decoding for
these codes.
And so, OK, not hard to get
2 dB of coding gain.
What happens if we go along
this line here?
These are all codes of
minimum distance 4.
Again, start here.
They're called extended
Hamming codes.
A Hamming code has minimum
distance three and is suitable
for hard decisions, single
error correction.
These codes all have minimum
distance four.
We've seen that it's always
worthwhile to add an overall
parity check to get an even
minimum distance, if we're
looking at Euclidean
space coding gain.
And so these are actually
slightly better
than Hamming codes.
They're called extended Hamming
codes, because they're
Hamming codes extended by
a single parity check.
They have one more unit
of minimum distance.
So again, asymptotically,
these are
called extended Hamming.
The nominal coding gain
goes to what now?
This is, the rate is
again going to 1.
The distance holds at four.
So the nominal coding gain
goes to 4, or 6 dB, while
again, the spectral efficiency
goes to two bits per two
dimensions, the nominal spectral
efficiency rate to 1.
But again, you have this
kind of phenomenon.
And I ask you to work that out
also on the homework, where
even though the nominal coding
gain plateaus eventually at 6
dB, there is a maximum effective
coding gain, which
is something more in the
range of 4 to 5 dB.
You figure out what it is.
And there's a limit to how much
effective coding gain you
can get with these codes.
Does this all makes sense?
Are you seeing how
I'm arguing?
OK, here's another interesting
sequence of codes.
These are all half-rate codes,
or nominal spectral efficiency
one bit per two dimensions.
I briefly mentioned that these
things pair up in duals.
The 16, 5 code is the dual
code of the 16, 11 codes.
If you see, there's a symmetry
about rate 1 by 2, such that
this is k, and this
is n minus k.
And so you would suspect that
this guy is the dual of this
guy, which it is.
This guy is the dual
of this guy.
And this guy is its own dual.
It's a self-dual code
of rate 1 by 2 or
spectral efficiency 1.
So these are self-dual codes.
And what does their nominal
coding gain go to?
Well, the rate is always 1 by 2
times four, that's a nominal
coding gain of 2.
This has a nominal
coding gain of 4.
The next one in line would be
a 128, 64, 16 code, nominal
coding gain of 8.
So the nominal coding gain
actually goes to infinity.
That's pretty good.
However, what is its
true meaning?
What we really want to
know is what's the
effective coding gain.
And given that the nominal
coding gain goes to infinity,
is it possible the effective
coding gain can get us all the
way to the Shannon limit?
Can we completely close
the gap to capacity?
As far as I know, this
is an open question.
I strongly believe that you go
along this sequence through
maximum likelihood decoding, you
will eventually get to the
Shannon limit, that is the
Shannon limit for this
spectral efficiency, which is
not the ultimate Shannon
limit, but rather is 0, in terms
of Eb over N_0 If you
remember, for rate 1/2 for rho
equals 1, the Shannon limit on
Eb over N_0 was 0 dB.
You may or may not
remember that.
So there's a question.
Does this take you all the
way to the Shannon limit?
And that would be a nice
question for somebody to
answer someday.
I think it probably does,
especially in view of the fact
that if you take this set down
here, again, this will be a
homework problem, this turns out
to be a set of Euclidean
images of these codes are
orthogonal signal sets.
For instance, 32, 6,
16, what is that?
That's a set of 64 constellation
points in 32
dimensions.
And algebraically, it's not hard
to figure out that every
one of these code words is
orthogonal in a Euclidean
sense to one another, except for
one that's complementary,
which is just what you expect in
a bi-orthogonal signal set.
So these give you bi-orthogonal,
they're called
bi-orthogonal codes, or
first-order Reed-Muller codes,
because the parameter r
is 1 for all of these.
What's happening to the spectral
efficiency here?
Spectral efficiency goes to 0.
So these become highly
inefficient from a bandwidth
point of view, as we already
know about orthogonal,
bi-orthogonal simplex
signal sets.
They use up a lot
of bandwidth.
But what else do we
know about them?
In this case, we definitely know
that the effective coding
gain does go to the Shannon
limit, and in this case, to
the ultimate Shannon limit
for rho equals 0 as
rho approaches 0.
So here, there's a proof that
these codes can get you to the
Shannon limit.
But as we've already explained
earlier, geometrically, it's
at the cost of using much more
bandwidth than you probably
really want to use.
But here, at least, is one
capacity-approaching set of
codes, just among these rather
simple Reed-Muller
codes along this line.
And of course, we also
see our repetition
codes, our trivial codes.
So this is a nice
representative family of codes.
And it really does tell you
quite well what to expect.
Are you looking at your watch?
Thank you.
I appreciate the hint.
So we didn't quite finish
chapter six today.
Next time, we'll start out with
the penalties of making
hard decisions, which at first
brush seems like a not
unreasonable compromise
to make.
But it actually costs
a serious penalty.
And that will finish
chapter six.
I'll do that as briefly
as I can.
And then we'll get into chapters
seven and eight,
which is finite fields and
Reed-Solomon codes, which are
the single great triumph of
algebraic coding theory.
So OK, that's tomorrow.